start with this new video from metro  police detectives say this video and  that person key in their investigation  into the murder of review journal  reporter jeff gehrman they want you to  look very closely at this individual pay  attention to how this person walks what  they're wearing the bag that this person  is carrying right now it's unknown  whether german was targeted because of  his job as an investigative journalist  or if perhaps he just encountered a  possible burglar in his neighborhood  metro says there have been a series of  burglaries with the suspect also wearing  construction type clothing police say  they do believe this is an isolated  incident the public is not in any danger  metro police are searching for this  vehicle they believe was involved in the  murder it is a red gmc yukon denali with  chrome handles a sunroof and a luggage  rack if you know anything that may help  detectives please call crime stoppers  702-385-5555 you can as always remain  anonymous